[Musique]
à
on sait le saint quentin et des yvelines
plus généralement c'est qu'effectivement
coexistent des industries qui sont très
très durement éprouvée aéronautique
automobile et des industries qui vont
d'une certaine manière bénéficier de d2
l'accélération produite par la crise
pense en particulier au numérique et à
la cybersécurité la question c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait dialoguer ces
acteurs-là faire en sorte que d'une
certaine manière la la faiblesse des uns
puissent faire la force des autres et
qu'on puisse unir nos forces sur ce
territoire
on est des entreprises qui vont bien
qu'ils sont très peu touché on a un
autre tiers qui qui va passer entre les
gouttes mais voilà qui souffrent et puis
un outil requis vraiment est en
difficulté
[Musique]